[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: The Google
Cloud SDK, what is it?
The Google Cloud
Software Development Kit
is a collection
of tools that are
used to interact with Google
Cloud APIs and services
and manage the resources in
your Google Cloud projects.
Together, these
tools help developers
and technical practitioners
be more efficient when
interacting with Google Cloud.
The SDK includes the Google
Cloud CLI, Cloud Client
Libraries, developer
tools and documentation.
The first piece of
the Google Cloud SDK
is the Google Cloud CLI, a
collection of command line
tools you can install to
access and manage your cloud
from the command line.
With it, you can do
all kinds of things,
like manage virtual machines,
query Big Query tables,
update Google Cloud
storage buckets,
and virtually anything else you
can do in the Cloud Console,
all from your Linux,
MacOS or Windows terminal.
Next in our SDK are
Cloud Client Libraries
for programmatically
integrating Google Cloud
APIs into your code.
With high level
API abstractions,
Cloud Client Libraries handle
all the low level details
of communicating
with Google Cloud.
This greatly reduces
the boilerplate code
you would have to
write otherwise
and lowers the learning curve so
you can hit the ground running
and start coding,
effectively and more quickly.
Most importantly, Cloud
Client Libraries are available
for several programming
languages, including Java,
Python, Node.js, GO,
Ruby, C# and PHP.
Each SDK will also have language
specific frameworks and tools
as available, so you'll
have everything you need,
no matter what your
favorite language is.
Cloud Client Libraries are
available for more than 100
Google Cloud Services.
To help you better understand
how to best use them,
the Google Cloud SDK also
includes detailed documentation
that we've centralized on
cloud.google.com so you'll
always have access to
consistent, authoritative and
up-to-date technical reference
documentation and code
snippets.
And finally, the SDK
optionally includes Cloud Code,
an ID extension available
for VS Code and IntelliJ that
helps you write,
debug and deploy
cloud native apps, all
without ever needing
to switch from your IDE window.
Do you want to get started
using the Google Cloud SDK?
The Google Cloud CLI is
available via your operating
systems package manager
or a direct download
from cloud.google.com.
And Cloud Client
Libraries can be
installed via standard library
package managers like npm
and pip, or via the language
specific Google Cloud Client
Libraries repositories linked in
the description of this video.
To learn more about
the Google Cloud SDK,
check out cloud.google.com/sdk.
[MUSIC PLAYING]